WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SATURDAY
SHOW.
TEN DAYS INTO THE MIDTERMS,
THANK GOODNESS.
THE LAST HOUR, PRESIDENT BIDEN
CAST HIS VOTE IN WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE.
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA TO HELP WHENEVER
VOTERS.
HE WAS IN MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN
TODAY BUT HE'S LYING TO VOTERS
ABOUT INFLATION.
>> INFLATION IS A PROBLEM.
WAS THE REPUBLICAN ANSWER?
THEY HAD A GREAT ANSWER, THAT'S
ONE THING BUT DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THEIR BIG ECONOMIC POLICY IS?
THEY WANT TO GOT SOCIAL SECURITY
AND MEDICARE AND GIVE TAX CUTS
TO THE WEALTHY AND THE MOST
EXCESSIVE CORPORATIONS IN THE
WORLD, THAT'S THEIR AGENDA.
>> JOEY, PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYS
IT'S TOO BAD REPUBLICANS DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER.
COULD AN ANSWER START WITH
OPENING BACK UP THE PIPELINES,
GIVING AMERICA ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AGAIN?
MAYBE THAT WOULD DO SOMETHING TO
TAKE US DOWN A BETTER PATH, WHAT
YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S GOOD TO BE A
POLITICIAN THAT'S NEVER GOING TO
RUN FOR OFFICE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU CAN SAY LITERALLY WHATEVER
YOU WANT AND BE APPLAUDED FOR
IT.
ONE THING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN,
WITH TALK ABOUT DEMOCRAT
FIGHTING, THEY HAVE TO LEARN NOT
EVERYBODY HATES PEOPLE
SUCCESSFUL AS MUCH AS AOC
PRETENDS TO.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO GIVE TAX CUTS TO THE RICH,
MOST OF MY FAMILY THAT ARE THE
OPPOSITE WOULD SAY I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU DO FOR THE RICH, GIVE
ME A TAX CUT AND MAKE THINGS
COST LESS.
WE HARD ON ENERGY AND THE BEST
WAY IS FUEL AT THE PUMP.
WE JUST DON'T TALK ABOUT HOW IT
TRICKLES INTO FOOD AND SHIPPING
AND TRANSPORTATION IN THE COST
OF MANUFACTURING BUT IF YOU GO
BACK AND MAKE IT MAKES SENSE TO
THE MOST BASIC AMERICAN ECONOMY,
$600 ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS,
WILL TAX YOU, WE CREATE MICRO
ECONOMIES IN OUR OWN HOUSEHOLD
AND MAKE MONEY AND TAKE YOUR
WIFE OUT TO DINNER, WHATEVER.
IF DEMOCRATS ARE GOING AFTER
THAT, WHAT WOULD TWO MORE YEARS
OF LEGISLATIVE POWER DO?
THEY COULD REWRITE THE TAX CODE
IN THE NEXT WEBSITE OF SEASON,
AMERICANS AREN'T GOING TO THAT,
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHAT REPUBLICAN
DO BECAUSE REPUBLICANS ARE ABOUT
DOING THINGS TO AMERICANS, THEY
ARE ABOUT TAKING THINGS BACK.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
REPUBLICAN PLAN TO CAPTURE THE
RISE INFLATION, LOOK NO FURTHER
THAN WHAT ECONOMIC POLICIES WERE
IN 2019 BEFORE START SPENDING
COVID AND DEMOCRATS PICK IT UP
AND TAKE IT TRILLIONS FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD.
>> UNDER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP,
TAX CUTS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
SOMETHING WE KNOW HAS BEEN A BIG
PROBLEM FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
ESPECIALLY BIDEN HAS BEEN TAX
PRICES.
LISTEN TO WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID
ABOUT GAS PRICES YESTERDAY.
>> SINCE ELECTIONS, WE'VE TAKEN
GAS PRICES DOWN.
>> TODAY THE MOST COMMON PRICE
FOR GAS IN AMERICA IS $3.39 DOWN
FROM OVER $5 WHEN I TOOK OFFICE.
>> HE SAID IT WAS DOWN FROM $5
WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE.
2.39 BIDEN'S FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE.
TODAY AT $3.76 A GALLON ON
AVERAGE IN AMERICA.
I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE PRICIER.
WHERE YOU ARE, THE ONLY PROBLEM
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE IS EVERYONE
KNOWS IT'S A LIE.
>> IN THE LAST WEEK OF GOTTEN
GAS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WINE
COUNTRY 6.59 FOR REGULAR.
CLOSER TO SAN FRANCISCO AIRPORT,
I PAID 6.99.
WHEN I GOT BACK TO FLORIDA, I
PAID 3.49 FOR REGULAR SO 3.99.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN SEES THIS.
GIVING THEM BACK THEIR MONEY,
TAX CUTS, THAT'S WHAT PART OF
DIXON THE ECONOMY.
BIDEN IS SIMPLY LYING, A SKILLED
POLITICAL LIAR AND HAS BEEN
SINCE BEING IN OFFICE.
HE'LL PUT YOU BACK IN CHANGE,
HE'LL TELL YOU REPORT THINGS ARE
NEANDERTHALS, THEY WANT TO DO
THIS BUT WHAT HE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IS WHAT HIS POLICIES ARE.
HE OMITS NOT JUST UNLEASHING
ENERGY, HOW IT FLOWS FARM TO
TABLE FOR THE COST OF DIESEL
FROM THE COST REGULAR GAS OR ANY
PRODUCT TO THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS TO THE SHORT WE ARE
WEARING, THE DRESS YOU ARE
WEARING, WHATEVER IT IS AND WHAT
WE WILL SEE IN THE UPPER MIDWEST
WITH GAS PRICES AND OIL PRICES
COMBINED.
FIVE OR $600 TO MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES BILL, THEY HAVE TO MAKE
HARD CHOICES.
THE ANSWER?
UNLEASHED THE ECONOMY, NOT JUST
ENERGY, ENERGY IS A BIG PART.
HOUSING STARTS ARE DOWN, FILINGS
ARE DOWN, 900,000 ONLY AVAILABLE
RESIDENTIAL RENTAL UNITS IN
AMERICA, BUILDERS AREN'T
BUILDING MORE BECAUSE IT COSTS
MORE.
CONCRETE IS UP, ADVOCATE IS UP,
WHAT IS UP, SUPPLIES ARE UP,
ELECTRICAL SUPPLIES ARE UP SO
MANY LOOK AT THIS, THIS IS THE
ECONOMY THAT NEEDS UNLEASHED AND
BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE A POLICY, HE
HAS IDEOLOGY DRIVEN BY THE LEFT.
>> AND ITS FAILING AND THE ONLY
THING DEMOCRATS HAVE IS
ABORTION.
LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN KAMALA
HARRIS BEATING THE SAME DRUM ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> I SAW TUESDAY NIGHT DOCTOR
OZ, GOD BLESS HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
THINGS THE RIGHT SHOULD CHOOSE
SHOULD BE BETWEEN A WOMAN, HER
DOCTOR AND LOCAL POLITICAL
LEADERS.
>> THESE FOLKS APPARENTLY
BELIEVE GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT WOMEN'S
BODIES.
>> THIS IS BASICALLY ALL THEY
HAVE, ABORTION.
WE KNOW THEY ARE NOT MAKING THE
CASE TO CONVINCE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
>> I WOULD SAY LOOK AT THE
POLLS, ECONOMY, CRIME,
INFLATION, EDUCATION AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS, THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO VOTERS.
SOME PEOPLE CARE ABOUT ABORTION
BUT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE?
NO.
POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS OTHER
THINGS.
>> LET ME THROW ONE THING AN